today we're going to talk about
blackheads and how you can naturally get
rid of your blackheads now like i said
in many other videos
to fix a problem you have to understand
it so i'm going to give you a little
understanding not too much not too
technical and then we're going to get
right into how to fix it but not the
typical fix where you're trying to fix
something from the outside in
by doing things on the skin
using pore strips like putting a tape on
and ripping it off no we're not going to
go there i'm going to show you how to
fix it from the inside out get to the
root cause rather than just keep
treating the symptom over and over
because you want to ultimately
make sure it doesn't keep coming back so
what is a blackhead
and also what is a whitehead okay
they're very similar
and they call them comedones okay
comedones and that comes from the latin
word which means to eat up which they're
relating to a parasite worm okay because
apparently
way back when they came up with this
name it looked like a worm so comadom
comes from the word worm-like now the
difference between a whitehead
which is called a closed comedome and a
blackhead which is an open comedom
really just boils down to this one thing
in a blackhead the material that's in
the pores okay that's black is being
exposed to air or oxygen so it's
oxidizing very similar to if you were to
cut open an apple and leave it exposed
to air it's going to turn brown right
same exact thing happens in your skin so
a closed homodome which is a whitehead
is like a little pimple it has a
membrane over the white material and so
it's not exposed to oxygen so it's not
going to turn
brown or black so that is the difference
so what we're dealing with is a clogged
hair follicle slash
problem with this sebaceous gland which
is the oil gland so we have this
combination of things happening and so
this material is a combination of and
you can call it pus which is oil
bacteria
and
keratin which is a type of protein so we
have oil bacteria and a little bit of
protein and that forms a little plug and
so what most people do which is a big
mistake is start to
over over wash it and try to clean it
out thinking that it's dirt or dirty
pores when it is not that it has nothing
to do with dirt in your pores but not
having that knowledge you might think
wow yeah i need to scrub my face more so
they scrub their face they over wash it
they use cleansers and they start using
this tape or it's called a pore strip
where they just put this on their skin
and they rip it off or their nose and
they're trying to pull this stuff out
the problem is they end up making it
worse because
they don't realize that there's this
layer of
friendly bacteria and other microbes
living on your skin that's part of your
immune system that's protecting you
against the bad bacteria and so when you
over cleanse or wash the area you
sterilize it and now you make your skin
wide open to becoming infected because
we do have a bit of an inflammatory
infection going on in these small pores
so why is this material manifesting
where is it coming from what's involved
well if you look deeper there's several
things going on
we have a spike in androgens okay and
you see this very commonly in puberty
that's why you see a lot of teenagers
with blackheads
and so androgens is a type of
testosterone it occurs both in boys and
girls and there is a weaker testosterone
and a stronger testosterone it's called
dht so basically
you see people with acne blackheads
whiteheads with more dht
so the question is where does that come
from
well that is coming from a spike in
insulin okay
and another hormone which is like
insulin called insulin-like growth
hormone number one don't get too caught
up into the name just realize that there
are two things that are making this
occur both of them increase the oil
production the size of the pore as well
as some of this extra protein material
but that's really interesting but it
doesn't really tell us what to do unless
we understand what triggers
insulin
and a spike in igf number one and that
would be three things okay refined
carbohydrates which is a pretty broad
category we're talking about the sugars
we're talking about the bread the pasta
the crackers the waffles the pancakes
all the things that you may love so
refined carbohydrates will greatly spike
insulin and crave this problem the next
thing that is on the list that's very
powerful
that's certain things in dairy think
about it what is dairy well dairy is uh
is milk that helps grow
a cow okay or other animals it's a
growth type thing so it's filled with a
lot of hormones that can affect our body
so any form of dairy whether it's
yogurt it's even kefir
cheese especially milk
can have a a big effect on your skin
especially if it's commercial where
they're you know adding other things in
there and the commercial milk
it comes from cows that are fed a lot of
omega-6 grains and they're not doing as
much grass
grass-fed cows have more beneficial
things that are less anti-inflammatory
but anyway all you need to know right
now is dairy can definitely worsen this
situation okay and the third thing is a
certain type of fat
and the type of fat that
makes things worse with blackheads
whiteheads and acne is omega-6 fatty
acids not all the omega-6 fatty acids
but most of them like the corn oils the
soil oil which is in
a lot of foods that have refined
carbohydrates it's in a lot of
restaurant foods okay so we have omega-6
fatty acids
corn oil canola oil
cottonseed oil
things like that and if you looked at
graph this over time
in our diets in the last 20 years we had
this massive spike in refined
carbohydrates sugar and also dairy in
different forms especially even the
sweetened yogurts
and a massive spike in the omega-6 fatty
acids all right so that's all very
interesting but now what can we do about
it what is the plan well number one
okay and this will work this is working
on the inside out you want to get rid of
these refined carbohydrates you want to
go a little carb if you're not familiar
with what that means i'm going to put a
link down below number two you want to
eliminate dairy right now okay all dairy
just get it out of the diet and that
includes even cheese okay and you're
going to see a huge change in your skin
all right number three we want to
decrease or eliminate all these extra
oils omega-6 fatty acids and you
probably need more information on this
especially if you don't know what i'm
talking about i'm going to put some
links down below because omega-6 fatty
acids are so
all over our diet that it's going to
actually quite surprise you so by
decreasing omega-6 fatty acids in
increasing omega-3 fatty acids
your skin is going to thank you okay by
not having these blackheads anymore or
even acne
so what is omega-3 fatty acids well that
would be like the fish oils
that would be like cod liver oil
especially because collagen oil has
vitamin d and vitamin a whereas the fish
oils don't but
if you start eating more seafood and
fish that would be a good idea
especially salmon or you can just use
some cod olive oil and
if you don't like the taste of that we
have them in capsules i put a link down
below all right in number four okay
this is the icing on the cake i'm sorry
i should talk about cake right now
borage oil
borage oil is a type of omega-6 fatty
acid it's called gla but
it doesn't create the normal
inflammatory situation that a lot of
these other omega-6 oils do
in fact it's anti-inflammatory it helps
thin the sebum or the oil it helps break
down the plug
that protein plug
which we want it helps reduce
oxidation in fact it creates an
antioxidant effect okay
and i mean a lot of people that take
borage oil notice a big change in their
skin so that's definitely something you
want to add to the list all right so now
that you have a plan for your skin the
next video to watch would be relating to
omega-6 fats okay so check that out i
put it right here
you